[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory we're
first introduced to Professor Horus slug
horn in the Half Blood Prince just
moments prior to Harry beginning his
sixth year at Hogwarts the introduction
occurs when Dumbledore and Harry visit
the home of horis Slug hornn and
Dumbledore persuades him to return to
Hogwarts eventually Dumbledore is was
able to successfully convince slug horn
to come out of retirement and teach
potions however had it not been for the
presence of Harry Dumbledore May well
have been unsuccessful you see Horus
sorn talented Wizard and respected
Professor was a bit of a social climber
and it was the opportunity to associate
himself with Harry that lured him back
to Hogwarts Horus said Dumbledore
relieving Harry of the responsibility to
say any of this likes his comfort he
also likes the company of the famous the
sucess uccessful and a powerful he
enjoys the feeling that he influences
these people he has never wanted to
occupy the throne himself he prefers the
back seat more room to spread out you
see he used to handpick favorites at
Hogwarts sometimes for their ambition or
their brains sometimes for their charm
or their talent and he had an uncanny
knack for choosing those who would go on
to become outstanding in their various
Fields Horus formed a kind of Club of
his favorites with himself at the center
making introductions forging useful
contacts between members and always
reaping some kind of benefit in return
whether a free box of his favorite
crystallized pineapple or the chance to
recommend the next junior member of the
goblin liazon office essentially Horus
loorn likes to pick favorites from all
of his classes he has a Keen Eye to
identify if someone will go on to
achieve greatness in some capacity and
takes great pride in their
accomplishments in the beginning of the
half bled Prince dumalo instructs Harry
to try and become chosen by slug horn
I tell you all this Dumbledore continued
not to turn you against Horus or as we
must now call him professor slug horn
but to put you on your guard he will
undoubtedly try to collect you Harry you
would be the jewel of his collection the
boy who lived or as they call you these
days the chosen one and after he agrees
to return to Hogwarts we just sort of
chalk up this bizarre behavior to slug
horn being eccentric not giving it much
further thought for the most part slug
horn is regarded as Charming jovial and
well- liked among students and staff
alike he had a talent for creating
positive and welcoming environments he
was also known for his love of the Finer
Things in life such as good food and
luxurious tastes what's more slug horn
was an excellent Professor showing
plenty of enthusiasm and providing
practical examples to help students
understand complex potion making
techniques and because of all of slug
Horn's positive traits people pretty
much took slug horn at face value we
later find out that slug horn had some
skeletons in in his closet like giving
Tom Riddle information on HW cruxes But
after those memories are extracted he's
still not exactly painted as a guilty
party he comes across as a sort of
unwilling participant divulging
information on a topic that he couldn't
have possibly considered the
ramifications of but here's my hot take
slug Horn's nature was a lot Darker Than
People realize I think that slug horn
undersold his level of participation
when it came to helping Tom Riddle and I
think that he's got some other dirty
dark secrets in that opportunistic brain
of his I've got three specific examples
theories so just hear me out H cruxes we
all know that slug horn divulged some
information to Tom Riddle on the topic
of Haw ruxers information that was Pride
out of him when he presented his
memories in Half Blood prints well you
split your soul you see and hide part of
it in an object outside the body then
even if one's body is attacked or
destroyed one cannot die for part of the
Soul remains Earthbound and undamaged
but of course existence in such a form
few would want it Tom very few death
would be preferable slug horn even
initially comes across as remorseful
having altered his memories to avoid the
shame of being associated with such a
conversation but when the truth came out
and it was revealed that slug horn had
indeed given Tom Riddle crucial
information on HW cruxes I still felt a
bit skeptical first of all why on Earth
did someone like slug horn know how to
make H cruxes the subject of H cruxes in
The Wizarding World is not only taboo
but also incredibly Uncharted most good
witches and wizards wouldn't be caught
dead learning about a subject like Haw
reers and seemingly no one else in the
series knows anything about them yet
here we have a good professor of Hogwart
students that knows them inside and out
secondly if sakorn was so ashamed that
he felt the need to alter his memories
once why not twice just because
Dumbledore got what he wanted out of
slug Horn's genuine memories who is to
say say that those memories weren't
altered as well perhaps when sorn's
memories were unveiled only a glimmer of
the truth Shone through perhaps SL horn
felt that by divulging some information
he could get them off the scent of a
much bigger secret which brings me to my
theory slug horn once had Ambitions of
creating h crugers no I don't think he
made one and I say that because I don't
think there's enough evidence to support
something like that but plans to make
one absolutely now let me first state
that sorn's aspirations to create hwr
came from a very different train of
thought than Voldemort slug horn didn't
necessarily want immortality or fear
death instead slug Horn's desire to
create a Haw Crux was fueled by his own
dark curiosity and Obsession paired with
a desire to preserve his knowledge and
influence slug horn known for his
tendency to collect and value
connections with influential individuals
may have wanted to preserve his wealth
of knowledge connections and influence
Beyond his mortal life creating a hawk
rugs could have been a means to ensure
that his legacy knowledge and influence
endure furthermore slug horn has
historically shown a fascination with
dark magic it's highly likely that slug
horn being a seeker of knowledge and
power may have been driven by the dark
curiosity to explore and experiment with
the creation of a
hawr however I do also anticipate that
slug horn wouldn't have had it in him to
mercilessly commit an act of murder
because of this aspect slug horn would
ultimately fail perhaps at least a part
of slug Horn's unusual demeanor can be
attributed to the fact that he's
harboring Secrets Dark Secrets which
brings me to my next Theory master
manipulator like I mentioned earlier
slug horn is known for collecting people
inviting them to his slug club and then
showing them off like trophies his
relationships with his prized students
are unusual to say the least viewing
them more as objects rather than
individuals in fact I'd be willing to
bet the slor would accept praise for the
accomplishment of his students but what
we have to remember is that sorn's
relationships with his prized students
are driven by a combination of
self-interest the desire for validation
and recognition the slug club serves as
a platform for slug horn to associate
himself with talented and influential
individuals which in turn reinforces his
own sense of importance and Status
within the Wizarding World slug Horn's
habit of showing off his prize students
can be seen as an extension of his ego
and need for admiration and here's my
hot take slug Horn's seemingly innocent
and jovial nature is just a facade and
by acting like this he's able to
manipulate events and people to serve
his own hidden agenda by showing off and
praising his students he comes across as
a nice guy but I think that's all just
part of the act one of sorn's skills is
his ability to identify and exploit
people's desires and insecurities he
knows how to play into their Ambitions
and craving for recognition using
compliments and praise to win their
favor by recognizing their talents and
making them feel special he gains their
trust and loyalty effectively
manipulating them into doing his bidding
and I think that slug horn deliberately
positions himself to befriend and Mentor
gifted students in order to later
exploit them or use them for his
Advantage now you might be thinking well
that's not exactly new information we
all know slug horn acts in his own
self-interest but my theory here posits
that slug horn has little genuine regard
for his students and that he operates
strictly in self-interest I also believe
that he has little moral compass when it
comes to which students he's willing to
make these connection with if he thinks
they'll do great things good or bad he
will Foster a relationship with the
student in order to better position
himself for the future from this
perspective it's highly unlikely that
slug horn felt true remorse for giving
Voldemort information on HW cruxes as
Voldemort to quote olivander for a sec
here did great things terrible yes but
great and that's it for this video do
you agree with any of my theories here
let me know down in the comment section
below also if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
live